two groups of opposing supporters goad
each other
outside the main vote counting center in
atlanta
and amongst each group there are some
who are heavily armed
tensions are high and the police are
trying to keep the different political
supporters apart
can you explain to us why you've come
armed like this
they came to my city with guns and we
know their intent who's they
trump supporters do you feel threatened
by them they come into my city that they
don't live in with guns
yes i feel very frightened the police
urged the trump loyalists to leave the
scene
the chasm between these two sides of
georgia is going to take time to bridge
hi
you're in trouble can you tell me why
you've come dressed like this
for security why what what do you feel
insecure about
you can intervene what do you feel
insecure about
our rights but you've come heavily armed
as if you're going to war
you didn't see them all day today
i i didn't i'm afraid i saw a lot of
people celebrating in freedom part but
tell me what your fears are
my fears they're gonna destroy this
nation
both sides are feeling decidedly edgy
black people are still not seen as
people
and this this guy that just got voted
out of office
is still spilling a lot of racial
tension we're just here to protect the
ship
you're trying to separate the two sides
no man
no separation at all we're just here to
protect the people
there's been a lot of threats being made
there's been a lot of wild things being
said
we just want to keep the peace that's
all that's why we're here the reason why
i have my gun is to defend
not to attack not to intimidate is just
to defend well why do you feel you need
to defend what's it you feel the threat
from what is the threat well the threat
is the threat is my skin color
you know there's a lot of people that
don't like my skin color
[Applause]
but there is jubilation too in the last
four years i have not been able to
fly the american fly the american flag
like like personally without thinking
okay
this guy now i can actually fly the
american flag
and think of my nation a country that
actually has room for me with kamala
harris with anybody else
it's going to take a lot of effort it's
going to take a lot of unity
but i think over time we'll be able to
come together
as a nation it's important to have
someone
who is going to heal the divisions
within the country
rather than intensify those like trump
was
and i think biden is going to do a good
job
there is hope and they're hanging on to
that right now alex crawford
sky news georgia